hello and welcome to
last day of june and probably the last
day of magnus june
uh hope you're having a great mid-week
late month um yeah i'm having a lot of
life
altering changes in june july so it's
kind of fun
i'm kidding it's not that big it's just
exams and exams and exams trying to
learn how to drive
gushing over my cat yeah
seeing if i can travel anywhere but
except for
my fun life events we got um
real life in person classes starting
actually from tomorrow
so if you are in saint louis and you are
around make sure to check in with the
club and join us for
in-person live classes and
yeah we got tournaments starting too
especially for
summer of chess july is going to be
filled with u.s championships juniors
seniors
girls boys everybody uh
i don't actually know sorry i'll retract
that just seniors
and juniors the women and men
championships are going to be late in
october
and then after that in august starting
pretty early on we are going to have the
center of this rapid and blitz followed
by sync world cup so we got a lot of
tournaments coming up
so if you are a chess lover sent this is
where you gotta be this summer
book your ticket yeah all right so
um i am hoping that
i was also thinking um since i'm going
like by months
and i'm not sure who i want to focus on
july but i think for august i might be
focusing on iranian
we can have it already in august out of
it
and yeah especially since i believe he's
actually
permanently moving to saint louis in
august
early august late june july i'd have to
double check that but i'm sure he'll
be moving here august so that'll be kind
of fun like welcome already out so
that's also um i was looking into some
of magnus's games and i was like man he
keeps winning games
and my initial thought was to show you
the cool game that duda
um beat magnus and he broke his streak
of what like
125
and i'm gameplay big fan of peppa i
didn't want to do
um like we already had that commentary
out there and
the video of it so i didn't really want
to repeat it but
from what i gathered nobody has done the
game on this
has like a video on this one from our
channel so that should be fun
let's go ahead and get started if you
have any questions feel free to pop it
in the chat i'm looking at the chats
constantly so this should be fun all
right
so there is a little spoiler alert here
so i apologize for those of you
who actually read the like to be
surprised it already says the manga
sloth
but that's okay we're here to still
enjoy
his techniques and we'll see why our
neonb team
this game was in 2020 and
so i wasn't that far that's long ago
but still alright so so far
not much in the chat so it should be it
should be good yeah this was um
i believe oh hold on
i might have misspoken
this game i analyze it in 2020 sorry
this was the norway chest the eighth
edition of it so not 2020.
oh i'll i'll double check that sorry
i got my dates wrong but the game is
still there the results are still there
so
anybody in the chat wants to correct me
i love being corrected
all right so so far
we got a very normal opening um not much
to talk about it's just another queen's
game but declined
and this was
a very fun game
especially because i believe
this was um yeah
this was the tournament that magnus
already lost to duda
and had already given up his um
his 125 unbeaten record but
it was still he had won the tournament
so it was going into the last round and
the result of it didn't matter as i mean
every every game matters but
he had already secured the first place
so that might have had some
psychological impacts and we are here
for chess on psychology so
i thought it's worth mentioning um but
there's not much special going on in the
opening this is
um i've actually been playing
this line as black since i'm thinking as
early as 2011
so 10 plus years i've known this theory
i mean it keeps adding up but the the
the bases are the same
white wants to develop what's going to
try to do the cross but
pawn structure stuff uh white's going to
try to
form a minority attack what's probably
going to try to do his best
to work both in the center and in the
queen side and
black is gonna try to stop that attack
take some control of the center and
queenside and so it's gonna be a fun
fight
um yeah so i actually wanted to
question the chat here black to move
what do you think we should do
the the the um move order kind of gave
black
a little leeway to do something
different
than if the bishop was already on d3
because
in carlsbad pawn structure we kind of
know
that there's gonna be a huge fight on
this diagonal right
so can black try to use that the fact
that there is no bishop on d3
yet castel is the normal stuff we want
we want a little more spicy
if you play normal stuff of minions
magnus he's
come gonna you to 16 different pieces
and you're not gonna really have a
chance to
um gain much from your normal moves so
what what else what else can we think of
am i a d4 player or e4 player uh i'm i'm
an e4 player i
tried around with retty i'm okay with it
but i i get more
out of e4 i'm more comfortable in the
positions i'm more
um familiar with what's going on i'm
definitely a e4 girl
so cast along is okay but castling does
not help us
win the fight for getting the bishop to
f5 so
what does help us get the bishop to f5
and i'll maybe give you guys another 20
seconds
but this is a this is not that hard of a
move just a little
unexpected
unexpected view
all right yeah g6 kinda looks weird
right because you don't
i mean your bishop is over here you
haven't cast those kind of feels like
you're
making your cake king a little naked
blake is the term we came up with a few
weeks ago
naked plus lonely so
we don't want that type of kings right
but g6 does make sense because there's a
huge fight for getting rid of this
bishop
and um getting rid of this bishop makes
more sense than
just castling and then then wasting so
many moves
tried to get into the bishop so when you
have the chance
do it already and then move from there
so now
castling is definitely possible but um
97 also makes perfect sense because you
want to
pay more attention to the e5 square and
so if like
90s because 95 is going to come up
sooner or later so it makes sense to
have your knights here already
and there are some maneuvers like this
and i think they're cool but at the same
time if you really want to get your
knight to e6 you could just
go the other way as well so it's not i
don't
feel that much of a difference with
knight a6 um
so knight d7 makes perfect sense keep
get the night outs you know where your
knight wants to go so
in this game magnus plays h4
so how do we feel about that i if i was
playing magnus and he played a sure i
would probably
need to talk for him i talked to myself
for about a minute to just tell myself
it's just a move
it's just another player it's not as
crazy you're not getting smashed
yet so uh yeah we don't h4 looks scary
especially when the super grand master
the world champion does it but
what do you think your position needs
and um it's kind of funny because
i remember i actually have been meaning
to show that game i might show that game
in july um yeah
the first time i played the tournament
that magnus was playing the same
tournament
um it was in qatar masters
back in 2015 and the first round he was
playing
uh this georgie and the well is your
grandmaster now
i think she i i think she was an
international master back then she
actually she got her gm title after
they were playing and a game isn't a
draw which was so fascinating for me
because
um like there was such a huge rating gap
and the fact that well it was a girl
very strong girl but still the rating
gap was there and the fact that i really
enjoyed that game so if you haven't
checked that game do that
and if you don't if you want to stay
patient then i'll
show that game in the coming lessons
but yeah um
we are on it thank you
yeah so what do you think what do you
think should happen now after this h4
i feel like i'm looking a little spooky
with the ipad
lights all right yeah so um
[Music]
these like h trees are more popular
and like normal stuff castle castle and
uh like there's going to be a fight and
whether or not white will manage to do
this
there's going to be subscribers thank
you there's going to be a fight on what
works
place this night and um there's going to
be a lot of these interesting little
tricks
but it's it's too bland
yeah i think that's their white use of
the word and
so even if i even if lights those
castles first
it's the same things you're eventually
gonna do this h3
and because your bishop needs a little
bit more to breed
and that's gonna still be the same stuff
again there's going to be a fight on
whether or not white you push
and yeah all right so h4
um the main thing to think is like do we
want to castle
is it time i don't think castling is a
bad idea but a5
is better if we were to castle then
h5 then you have to kind of deal with
these kind of threats
so i'm just going to ask you how do you
feel about this
do you think white has enough
[Music]
compensation
oh i see some farce in the chat
asking for recommendation for beginners
well
for beginners uh depending on the age
uh i found that having like a study
buddy like a
chess study buddy could be very useful
then keep each other accountable
and um generally trying to work on
calculations first like understanding
how to evaluate
calculate having a solid opening choice
not necessarily like too many different
openings but
just having a basic understanding of
what's going on in the game that
you play if you play d4 if you play e4
whatever you play just having a very
basic understanding of different
positions that could
happen and just being able to calculate
calculate efficiently starting with two
moves upping it to five moves it's
the more you do the better so tactics
calculation
and openings for like beginner are the
keys
and as you improve then understanding
more strategy in the middle game is
their priority
and then adding more openings and then
adding more middle gear
and game understanding so yeah
art our channel youtube channel and
twitch channel they're both
very great for you well any
any level so feel free to scroll through
them
and join us for live sessions
all right so yeah i wouldn't really i
mean i feel like black is
fine but you don't want to exactly
get such an ugly position like you're
not losing white doesn't have advantage
but white does have
um white does have
a clear clear compensation
so we don't want we don't want to be
dealing with um
this this this much pressure
it's too much pressure to just for one
exchange
it's not worth it even if you try to run
away and make your position a little bit
more pleasing
it's still black is doing okay but it's
very frustrating yeah your king is naked
so yeah we don't want to do we don't
want to get into that too fast
uh bobby that is a very fun
thing to do um the good news is that we
are going back
live um going back to stream from the
club and doing classes from clubs so
i might not need them i don't think i'll
need that but
thank you for the thought
i don't understand the question
all right so a5 we talked about cost by
pawn structure there are way
more videos out there for you to watch
as well but the main
thing about the um
a5 the crossbar bonus structure is that
white wants to fight to win the
advantage in the queen side gets space
get some initiative why don't you do
stuff nasty stuff in the queen side and
we want to stop it
so in order to stop it a5 makes perfect
sense
and i really like what levon did here
uh castling would be way too premature
so
now cast the length is
not as pretty as it would be if we just
played h3 right
so castling alongside this also has
its yeah exactly minority attack and
castling
alongside also stops all minority
attacks here and this king also feels
quite exposed because i'm already going
at it with my pawns
so this king is having some issues what
do you guys think or girls think what
this king should do
oh yeah well depending on how um
depending on how um how good your
calculations
is yeah
uh gg no not necessarily i was looking
for good games and i was like ah magnus
won again another one he wins
let's see how does he win this one now
it's two and gaming net this is two
opening e
and i came across this one and i was
like oh this is a good game
kind of got whooped so i was like why
not let's wrap up the
the june magnus magnus june with um
with a whooping yeah i wanted to do the
dudeo one but i have done i think i feel
like i've done that before at least on
twitch channel
and peppa did it on the youtube channel
so it would be too
too much repetition
yeah king f1 and so that's another thing
that's
i don't know how i feel about it so uh
we did another very beautiful game of
magnus
sometime last year i think it was with
dingleran
or i'm not sure um which chinese player
it was but i'm sure it was a chinese
player
uh oh it could have been hong kong
anyways
i remember magnus was wide and he played
the beautiful king e2 move and the title
for that
video was um should we castle
so if you want feel free to check that
out
and yeah so this idea of like
mine is not castling is not a new thing
i feel like it just goes with what the
position
needs but i don't think necessarily
right
now is um
the best idea to do
all right so oh i see a lot of chats
coming up
where am i from oh that's fun that's a
fun game to play
you want to play that where is she from
game
you have three guesses i have not
covered games from the last i've been
trying to cover more in person games
because
with online games i've realized that a
lot of streamers
just kind of like everybody is already
covering those so i've been wanting to
hit a little bit more
um past years then this is not
necessarily like
online games here and
so i hope that answers your question
anyways yeah king f1 i'm not the biggest
fan of it
he really refuses to castle and the king
is
well safe and rookie one will come up
and then e4 can be played so it's not
something to
be worried about but it's
it feels a little out of harmony all
right anyways
let's push this pawn and that was what
we wanted to do we wanted to
completely [ __ ] the the queen side
all right um it is for sure we are not
going to do lawn caster we
at some point are going to short castle
so is it the time to do shorts castle or
do you think we can make more out of our
queen because those are kind of your two
choices
your bishop can't do much your knights
are fine where they are at the moment so
can you make uh can you develop your
queen or is it time to castle
i am not from pakistan i've actually
never been to pakistan
so weird because iran has borders with
that with them
but hold on do we have borders with them
i know it's the same region oh boy my
geography
iran bordering countries okay
yeah we do it's a little lower okay
for a second i felt like my geography
teacher from
middle school would come haunt me
tonight
yeah queen v6 queen b6 and you have a
threat
it's not as crazy of a threat
but upon us upon whoa it's gonna get
thunderstormy
here since this has been so weird
weather-wise the last
week or so it like it it's so hot out
there it's like
80 degrees it can't go up to 90 degrees
and then
bam it rains like this and you never
know when the rain is gonna hit you
it kind of feels nice so i stopped
carrying around umbrellas
but then i'll be like
which is the translation would be in
english um
with mouse the farsi translation is much
better but anyways
yep it's raining now and my cat gets
scared of the rain so he always comes
cuddles with me
which is a bonus so i guess i actually
enjoy the rain because my cat gets
scared and he gives me cuddles so
yeah back to the chest of it um b2 is an
important pawn you don't necessarily
want to just you know give it up
and another idea with queen v6 is this
potential for queen exchange
so marcus just played queen c2 defending
this and avoiding any type of
queen pinning and i like that i agree
with that
now okay we are again at that point
can i castle is is it safe to castle or
should we try to blockade this h5
first before we castle that's another we
have these another two ideas should we
block it before we castle
oh yeah did you he was so pretty he's
such a precious kitty
always napping when i'm when i have
something serious to do
he's a very good boy
alright so it's not safe to cast those
so let's say not castling yet so
what is my best choice of blocking this
i can push pawn i can put
knight there which one do you think is
better
and oh boy why is my laptop overheating
i feel like my laptop is about to go
boom
yeah i agree h5 is the best one
because even if you were to play this
knight h5 not necessarily right now but
eventually
g4 will kick you out so it's kind of
pointless
long run and your knight here is very
just sad too
yeah bishop g5 and then what would you
do f6 the bishop goes to h6 kind of
messes with your whole structure yeah
h5 stopping this
whole shebang's over here and now
we want to castle uh king g1
seems to be a nice suggestion like a
fake castle type
uh but magnus chose a little bit more
active
choices and i was probably a little more
violent too bishop g5
it's not exactly threatening anything
too scary
knight e5 will come up there is
potential for e4 if i keep my king in
the center
because you remember that was one of the
original ideas that was
suggested after king f1
so now after bishop g5 is it time to
castle
yes finally let's put this game to
safety
and magnus went for knight to e5 i think
now this e4 would be a little pointless
because your own king is more
close to center than my king so the e4
idea at least for the time being is
not as uh great
here for careful taking check
and also grabbing the knights
yeah that can't happen
all right so we got the king in the
safety
and now i'm knight e5 how do you feel
about that
yeah there is quite a quite a huge
rating difference
uh gj actually tomorrow we are
going to be uh streaming but
it's not going to be from this well
actually
the part of it is going to be from the
studio but we're also going to be doing
live lessons
so if you guys if any of you people are
asness feel free to pop up tomorrow at
the club we're going to have live
lessons
again for your double check the time
that will change the space make sure
everything is set but
yeah call the club and join our live
class
in person if you can't make it because
you're probably another
city or country feel free to join on
youtube
and ben simon will be helping us stream
it
yeah brian clark that's that's kind of
fun right
ah king g7 so
whoa that is big rain
holy god
no i'm afraid i'm not the biggest fan of
thunderstorms
rips me out anyways
cool uh the big problem right now is
take
take and your bishop will be falling so
king g7 does not help you with that
what are the classes about um it's
supposed to be
one hour of my choice and one hour of
games of the week
i have no choice yet
and i have not decided on the games of
the week i know i want to do something
about first job because it was his
birthday recently and i just
feel like he's a cool kid so i probably
do
one or two of the games related to him
but that's the best i can
give you details on at the moment
so this is a scary thing that's going to
happen so be
our bishop is defenseless we got two
choices
either you gotta defend the bishop or
you're gonna run with the bishop which
one do you think is best
defend the bishop or run with the bishop
yeah rookie yay thank you
izzy isadora yeah ricky hates
that makes sense right you're defending
your bishop you're developing your rook
normal moves and also
kind of this night's g6 is something
that we
should keep in mind that's um we don't
necessarily you know
love it so i rook g8s
i feel like i from now on i don't really
need to shower in the summer it's just
going to go under up here like take a
soap
shampoo two minutes and it will be over
i feel like showering in the summer when
there's this crazy rain is
sin but yeah
feel free to check the sandless weather
right now and
you'll be very surprised because i'm i
am right
cool well why should we defend the the
bishop that is good question
uh the bishop is this knight's
knight e5 is not just attacking your
knight he wants to make this night move
so then the bishop falls
there is lightning there is crazy rains
there is uh potential for
flood so
yeah move to the midwest
and you'll have crazy stuff all right
um i'm gonna stop complaining about the
weather because that's the one thing i
can
never fix i could move somewhere else
but
they don't have a sandwich just go up
there so
all right
yeah so what do you think about knight
g6 good bad cuckoo bananas what do you
think
oh andrea yeah that is that is also
correct
i have some furniture in the patio and
the rain is
already kind of coming up so they're
about to float around
this is so much fun
no preacher is not hiding in the bed his
majesty is sitting on the rock and just
watching the crazy rain if he gets
scared enough he'll join me and
give me cuddles why isn't he scared of
this is pretty scary right
all right yeah nigel six is not
really working right now because um
white could try for advantage but it's
not
really easy and it's not really clear
and like this could be a plan
but the the pieces are not as ready as
we want it to be
um yeah this queen side
like you can drop the pawn and then your
pieces are not
exactly ready for this attack either
so i think it's worth it but
not in such a high level
ah she's scared he's joining
yeah it's i feel like this would this
would work if like max was playing like
a 2200
but because auronian is such a well
master himself this might have not been
the wisest choice for magnus
all right
now i'm a little worried about wi-fi
problems so far we're good so i'm gonna
not gonna jinx it well oops kind of said
it already
anyways uh now i decided to go for this
a little more clever way so he took over
here
we take back and then rookies three so
he still keeps the threads but he's not
doing it just
yet he's kind of like i'm gonna use a
far c expression and then i'll give you
the english translation
um
so like keeping that thread is much more
frustrating and exhausting for black
then
actually executing it
so grade 12 the problem is not the
calculation the problem is that the
lack of peace activity if this knight
for example goes over here over here
yeah definitely we should have done it
but there's there are not enough pieces
for magnus to do that
and that's the reason he didn't go for
it but now he wants to
now he definitely wants to go at the g6
pawn
and something like king f7 is like
moving the king doesn't help something
like moving the king
still there's rook g3 this is a huge
problem now
so we can't um that's not like he wants
to you he wants to do that now
andre i believe that's what i was trying
to say
and failed a little saying so
all right so what do you think should
happen now
oh storm is scary with or without
thunders as long as there is like crazy
rain coming up consider me terrified
so let me let me try to question uh
perform this question a different way
so we know what what magnus wants now
should we try to exchange queens
do you think that's a good idea
yeah i mean it's a good idea because
it's such a
such a scary um position right now and
we can't just let the opponents do
whatever they want so in the best way to
stop it
queen b3 and in the game magnus was like
uh-uh i'm going to change this well
hopefully he did that on his mind
because that would be a cool way to
refuse
but he just went for coin b1 logical
move
still keeping pressure over here
alright so we got this cool pressure
uh he refused point exchange now what
should we do
we still need to deal with this threat
of knight taking g6 and rook coming to
g3
what is the best way of stopping us we
clearly know
why what white wants to do so
what can we do as black
well defending g6 might not be as well
i agree with defending g6 but um how
are we trying to do that directly
because with the king is not going to be
enough the rg3 will still come up
bishop d6 uh interesting but
still taking is a problem
can't exactly take because now after
clean tanks the rook jumps this is
falling
we could do like a knight d4 knight g4
here
but i don't think bishop d6 is the
strongest one
this diagonal is a problem so can we
block it
yeah i like that i think knights e4 or
knight g4 i think those two moves are
the best ones
and also i just wanted to mention if
take this is also a possibility
um and
psychological wise most likely if magnus
definitely like needed the point he
would have gone for this
because as i said earlier he this was
the last run of the tournament and
magnus had already won the tournament so
maybe he didn't feel the need to um
to do we just wanted to like make the
game beautiful rather than
fighting in an end game that's a little
boring that's
not as clear as his chances so
yeah um that's like a suggestion that
actually my brother gave
when we were talking about it because
this is one of the games that we
actually included in our upcoming book
i wrote a book with my brother and so it
was kind of fun to um
talk about different positions and
you know uh
gently scream at each other about i
think this is right no i think this is
right no say that don't say this it was
very fun
it was very good team bonding experience
so if you want to write a book with
someone make sure to
um have a good voice box
i'm kidding there was no screaming
from his side at least yeah
uh like v3 is a good idea queen b1 i
completely
i think that's something i would have
done but my structure is different but
i'm
generally more comfortable with in the
middle game position unless my
my position needs it to go into the end
game so if i
if my position doesn't absolutely need
me to exchange the sub to go set
game i'm not going to be doing that
anywho yeah knight t4 is a good idea
knight g4 is also possible because it
stops these that side of it
but knight g6 is still a little
problematic and even if you go for
bishop d6 uh you kind of just gave up
the pawn i don't
see why we need to do that
94 simple
and now this is a little different we
gave up the pawn
but we get to activate our pieces and if
any of my camp kids our
virtual class kids are here you all know
what a big sucker i
am for peace activity not sacrifice
anything for peace activity reasonable
yeah so it's got preventing all these
cuckoo banana night ideas it's
preventing all these
take now you actually have suggestions
preventing all these rook moves
not preventing but dimming it down yeah
so um sandy died the moving the knights
to go to f8 might have been interesting
but knight e4 is
keeps your position much more active and
we like peace activity
chess players like peace activity
um now let me ask you a question why not
to eat the pond
izadora i yeah i thought about that
while i was saying it so i was like
let's add the reasonable
in there
a very curious cat staring me down
but he's not scared enough to come give
him a hug so
so yeah the problem is just simply rugby
one if you are
cuckoo enough to eat this now you're
gonna have to deal with
uh actually a full balloon full blown
attack and this is not gonna be enough
because
now g6 pawn was falling
and this is this is this is lost
you could try to save the game with
queen a2
and defending your f7 pawn but
why would you give your opponent this
much activity and this much
um potential for
just for why would you do that i i don't
support this idea i don't support
giving this much up for just
maybe a perpetual if opponent goes where
no wires would have
wife would have the upper hand here so
this pawn is poison fruit at the moment
bishop d6 keep your peace activity next
you can eat that if you want
but now well we can still
we can't really take that just yet so
let's get rid of this night first
this is another problem so yeah the
problem with taking
is that now oops sorry the problem with
taking now ah
the problem with taking now yeah is that
now blue white gets the chance to do
perpetual
and if you're happy with the drop you
can do it but this position
now black has the upper hand and
there's there are different reasons for
that because well first of all
the pawn structure is too floppy i can
definitely try to eat some of
the rooks are misplaced they're not
really in harmony with each other
white kind of doesn't really have any
other ideas but it's kind of running out
of ideas
so that's another aspect to keep in mind
now
queen b5 check was played and now what
should we eat this
do you want to eat that with the drug or
with the queen
which one do you think maximizes black's
chances for
fighting for a win
so why to move sorry black to move what
should we eat that
white pond with
clean our work either ways we have to
just keep
this into consideration take this into
consideration
i think clean takes is good but it's not
really that strong
the problem is that first of all even if
take
take and
activating the stroke we do have pawn
majority on the queen side
but we don't when we have pawn maturity
the devil is very important and white
kind of guessed that already
but we still do have a chance to
continue
fighting for a win but we would have a
better chance if we take that with the
rook
um taking it also does not guarantee
queen exchange
you can just go queen before and ignore
the queen exchange
and your position is again black is
fine there's nothing wrong with it but
it's kind of like a inaccuracy
taking with the rook is just a little
bit more um
in favor for black now
what does rook g6 work let me question
this first
because if this works then it doesn't
make any sense if white can still
make a draw then we kind of spend this
time
talking about taking with the rook
for nothing so can black
escape the potential draw here
we have two choices run or take
which one would you do
and if you guys are watching this after
the live stream feel free to leave it in
the comments
take or nuts
so yeah the problem is that taking
still gives whites the chance to um
grab the draw and
this is not really going to work that
pretty for me and king
e8 it's going to be a huge mistake
because
now i'm losing my pawns and my king
and white actually go is going to be
able to win this
so fg6 not a good idea however we can
run we are keeping these threads we are
attacking this queen
and white is completely busted
you're kind of forcing the rook to drop
so it looks a little weird i agree
because
there is this diagonal happening and
it's a
little brutal but it's just it just
looks scary there is nothing scary about
it
there is no double checks with the rook
that works there are no
threats to threatening my queen or
whatever you were completely fine
so having established that rook g6
does not work it's a very very huge step
so
uh queen d4 was played in the game and
then magnus went ahead trying to get the
pieces a little bit more harmonized
and again rg6 would not work
now because you could take it and my
rook is already kind of
a file closer to my king
but now after rook f5 we can
activate the queen so eventually we want
to be able to activate the stroke too
but right now this rook is i can't
really get it to where i want
so let's go for a more clear attack
uh queen d5 is also worth mentioning but
this is much stronger
and now e4 was a
uh interesting way to try to
defend this the other way would be just
to do a very passive work of one
and then we could shift this and go from
the second rank
however after e4 this is
now a new weakness yes they're attacking
my rook
but i can simply just go at it from the
different side
uh rook f4 again worth mentioning and
then why we could do like
f3 and my rook is a little misplaced
here i could take it but
the rook is not as active as we want it
to be
so that's another thing to keep in mind
so rook five keep your pieces active
guys
peace activity is very crucial
trying to defend boom going after here
now um it's kind of funny well not funny
maybe just
painful actually for magnus because
iranian
is kind of questioning this rook if you
move it
i'll eat this if you don't move it then
you gotta exchange queens
and your jerks are more passive than
mine so what do you want do you want to
lose this pawn
or do you want to go to an end game
where i'll have better shot at winning
and magnus chose queen d3 logically
because this pawn would be falling if he
didn't
now we're not gonna just take it so that
he can
so that magnus can get the rook activity
here
however we are going to defend this
lovely queen
and now i'm gonna
take a quick break and ask you guys why
why just played b3 so black to move what
do we do
well i'm gonna go cuddle with the kitty
because he's scared of the little boy
he does not like rain
it's a he and i call him cat literally
fine fine you're he i made sure to
mention that
i'm sorry you came for cuddles and i
all right
well you guys got your weekly dose of
peachy
easy so what do we want to do
we don't want to take that we don't want
to um
we don't want to just give this whole
file to opponents
no if we take it then this rook will
take back
actually either rook and this is not
really we still have to play this b5
anyways so if we have to play b5 might
as well play it now
because if you were to take it now i can
take with the rook and then
whoa i can take it with a rug and now my
rook is becoming more active see it's
all about peace activity
he is a big boy yeah yeah we're going to
activate so b5
magnus onto rook d3 trying to gain some
control over this file now we can take
it
because you kind of wasted a move and
now you take back boom by bring up my
rook
well the d file is important but not not
as important as pawns
in the endgame especially if i have
enough piece activity i can get away
with giving up the file
because i have i have other files that i
can take over
and so it's it's kind of
weird because now magnus was a little
too stubborn to um
acknowledge or agree to like simplifying
the position trying to gain some
counter play and like training up some
rooks these are some stuff that
that's not the best way to do you know
you can just try to keep it simple
defend your pawn go for a draw settle
for a draw
and that was not his style and he
unfortunately good for
good for us good for this uh
good for this video he was too stubborn
to do that and he just
went for exchanging the rooks and
taking would be an interesting choice
uh yeah
taking would be interesting and then you
take over here
but this could also make it too simple
and we don't necessarily want to make it
too easy for
opponent you know this is not exactly
winnable
so uh
in order to keep it more spiced up or c4
was played
rejecting this kind of typical draw and
okay now finally f3 and it's time to get
the kings in the game
and i'm going to take another quick
question of black to move
what to do
so what do you think black should do now
we still got some pieces to activate
this could be better
uh anna's that is not arabic that is
farsi
and it's june not jon june and far
siemens deer ergo the
the title dear magnus i kind of did a
ward pawn
with june the month june and the words
june
and farsi yeah king u5 would actually be
the best
but arnie did not do that
and then later on f5 would make it more
interesting and if i could do some cool
stuff at rook t7
i can simply go after your pawns there
and i'll have two
connected passports this is going to be
easy win
however kingifa was not played and
iranian simply went for rook c4 i can
only imagine
that he um he was
arya was under a lot of pressure that he
didn't necessarily want to
um give up the d the the seven track
that easily but that's what that would
that would have been the best move of
the position jd5
now trying to get a little bit more
spice in the game
finally king e5 came along and now rook
c3 so
remember the rook was already here so we
didn't necessarily
like if you wanted to play kinky five it
would have made sense to do it last
month but i can also imagine that the
players were in time trouble at this
point
so things aren't really going that easy
for either one
all right so uh yeah rook c3
and trying to attack here defending it
defending my pawns
bringing the king closer going after
this so this
is interesting but instead of
king d6 rook b3 would have been the
better
or even b4 or even king d4
these are some of the ideas that would
have been better instead of bringing the
king all the way to just go attack the
rock
uh yeah those would be a slightly more
accurate but there's
it's not this is not a bad idea it's
just a little
less accurate than the other ones and
anywho uh we managed to
[Music]
get this king in a very awkward position
on the queen side and we're leaving all
of our
pawns kind of lonely on the king side
but we're going to be able to create
these connected passports so
it's kind of a to give something up to
get these
but is it going to be enough well the
result tells us yes
but um the game could also be a little
a little more uncomfortable fun thing
a4k5
uh this rope is kind of trapped here
because now uh you can simply just start
pushing this pawn
this rook is trapped can't go anywhere
can do anything a lot of fun right
all right so uh mike let's clearly knock
over that
and take take take take
and let's push pawn so now
here is actually where magnus kind of
messed up
before that arunian had better chance
he never had a winning position up until
here
now i'm gonna ask you uh should white
push or should i take which one do you
think is better
what do you think is the mistake that
magnus made
so what do you guys think take not take
yeah push would be the best one but
magnus made the mistake of taking over
here
and this is such a huge mistake
this is a deadly race that now is going
to be lost
and uh white can't stop the spawn white
can't push in time
let me show you what happened
and this is actually what happened in
the game careful b2
it now it could be stopped
and these two pawns are strong enough to
face off the stroke
when it comes to that
and also this should be a draw but even
if the game play that different than if
you gave up this pawn and
uh these two would be strong enough to
stop this trick
yeah so b2 would be a bad
horrible mistake irony and went for c5
slowly slowly push these pawns and the
magnus
already resigned here because this is
completely lost
as soon as you do this king b4 and c2 it
was a very terrible
mistake because magnus kind of gave up
the full point
when she could have easily tried to
um have the draw only if you push the
pawn
i'm gonna go back and show you that line
that magnus missed
it was kind of weird because even though
he lost this game he already won the
competition
so you never know could have been a
little psychological pressure
since he already had won the tournament
you know it's like um
maybe loosened up a little but i
i don't know i'm not magnus can't speak
up but that's what makes the most sense
so taking not a good idea h5 makes the
most sense that would be the best idea
and if you push
now check and b2 would actually be a
horrible mistake because the
the pawn drops let's say we play it
correctly
and play like king b7
now this could just easily be a drop
even if you try rook a7
okay check bring this back
now even take take and pushing here
works for
white it is going to be just in time
and that would work nicely so yeah that
is a very
sad ending for um magnus
june month but very happy to start
around
so we're gonna see more of the um
these super chess players play full
moves cool games
and um yeah so yes we are going to have
a switch to twitch segments we are we do
that every wednesday we're going to
analyze our games so
if you have a game handy and if you're
going to we are going to
be doing that for the next two hours so
we're going to take a short recess about
maybe 10 minutes
and join us on our twitch channel have a
game ready
we're going to be working on lycha so
please send us alicia's link
and yeah i'll see you in luiges